We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p we often talk about the uh, lower
age limit to be president of the United States.
You can't be 17 and be president.
You can't be 21 and be president.
Okay.
This color has a question about a different
sort of age limit, an upper age limit on the
presidency.
David, this is Dave from California.
I want to ask you cashed your viewers a question
and it's a good question.
Oh well I'll, I'll be the dude to that.
There'd be an age limit if you're going to
be elected president of the United States,
former president.
Jimmy Carter thinks there should be an age
limit.
I think there should be an age limit only
because the job is so tough.
You know what I mean?
It can be so tough.
So I think liking 70 year olds, maybe it's
a little tool, but I could be wrong, but I
think that would be something to do.
A poll on there.
Bye.
All right.
Well the color, very, very confident that
it is a good question and telling me that
a poll should be done.
But, so here's the thing.
I am open to the idea of an upper age limit
to the presidency, but as I talked about several
weeks ago, what about not setting an upper
age limit but just requiring in some way,
uh, that candidates take a cognitive assessment,
a real one, not the Montreal cognitive assessment,
but it actual proper cognitive assessment.
And when I suggested that a few weeks ago,
some people wrote in saying that it is ageist
to only require people of a certain age to
take the cognitive assessment.
I mean I have no problem just saying any major
party nominee should agree regardless of their
age, to take a cognitive assessment that may
circumvent some of the difficulties of setting
an upper age limit on the presidency.
I am not against it in principle.
I just think that the application in any,
so you know the concern about ageism, anytime
you're talking about age limits for anything,
anytime you're talking about after a certain
age, you have to be retested to maintain your
driver's license.
For example.
If it is based on age, you are always opening
yourself up to the possibility that it could
be deemed age.
[inaudible] the question is what science backs
up whatever it is that we are trying to implement
or or put in place, uh, and can it be applied
in a way where even if the concern is about
people of a certain age, you are still at
least applying it in a way that equal under
the law when it comes to age.
And I think the answer is we could if we decided
that this was a priority.
Now from a practical perspective, I don't
know that this really is a priority, um, that
that is going to make its way, maybe not even
into the law, but just into tradition, uh,
as something like releasing your tax returns
has become mostly tradition which Donald Trump
decided to ignore.
Uh, but I think that there's definitely an
interesting conversation to be had on today's
bonus show.
The U s abortion rate is at it's lowest ever.
The pro-life right is saying it is abortion
bands that have been the cause of that.
I disagree.
Studies disagree.
We will talk about that on the bonus show.
I will also talk about Joe Kennedy formally
announcing that he is going to be running
for Senate.
And lastly, Burger King, not only now offering
the impossible burger, I believe it's called.
They also in the UK are getting rid of all
of those plastic toys from kids' meals for
environmental reasons.
We will talk about, is it possible that these
fast food chains will become the good guy
at some point?
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show, two ways to get access,
become a member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.